[Music]
damn bloody fake guns barn I'm not
having this house don't Bros you're
about to watch me get the absolute
scared out of me this show takes what I
already do getting scared of horror
games but taking it to the next level I
really up you're gonna log scare
mr. PewDiePie hey no come on come over
the top
stop goofing around don't grab onto that
that's what broke last time all right
all right
how's gonna practice tonight we're gonna
go to a doctor who wants to discuss your
the results of your medical test we did
the first day know if they're gonna
reverse you're good to talk about my
results yeah yeah so there's someone who
is new to our crew tonight Jeff this is
Felix Felix is Jeff yeah there's been
some security issues I understand they
asked me come on extra person to help
out do the eyes and ears okay somebody
comes down they just asked me to have
extra okay yes cuz I don't trust those
doctors all right let's go
okay so you've had a couple great
gameday plays right yeah last one was
awesome
are you pretty playing yeah yeah I will
take very good care of I'm sorry I'm
packing tonight I just wanted you to
know what is packing
here's a weapon I've got a gun just want
you I'm a big fan so what are you doing
today well meeting doctors at 9:00
that's not weird at all
okay will you put that on yeah damn it
great great guy it's great Hospital guys
my favorite so far why is it so freaking
hot I just want you to start
concentrating feel like what is that you
just need to use your senses what is
that keep walking Damon and why do you
have to do that
goodbye mm-hmm for now for now good luck
thank you
okay
you fool
agitate to all the patients okay just go
to your room it's after curfew what's
the time for you to relax no this is
what they always say just come and sit
here
listen relax it just take a lot of it
relax your feet sit down and we meant to
make sure that nothing happens to you
everything will be completely just you
need to be uncertain wrong are you for
me
now getting you listen we had this
discussion what Felix I'm sorry this
keeps you safe there's nothing to worry
about
don't struggle it'll be less comfortable
remember no one is released until the
paperwork is signed by dr. Yates I would
kill to know where your papers are this
is oh hey how's you
going how you doing
oh yes okay great I'm this favorite well
let's see and thank you very much
Oh sake which one is that
come on guys
I'll get none of these fed ha ha really
funny
thanks a lot Shawn the way to be
oh
come on okay there you go genius strikes
again not a problem
okay cool just right back okay good
great gonna go home get a hot chocolate
mr. chat we'll be out of here yeah but
first we need to get your paperwork up
on end and I'll take you to where you
need to go okay hey
great this is amazing take me to the
exit okay I don't think no you're not
mr. chair what are you doing I'm cute I
gotta get you through this holler
crazies then we're gonna go to the
chapel we're gonna go to the chaplain
grace can wait okay oh is
doing okay thank you mr. J is there nice
will you come back I'll be waiting for
you okay just wait that
okay what do we got lights check
this is my favorite Chapel of all time
around and I'm supposed to be crude
you're gonna need oh you're gonna need
those inmates go oh oh dude no oh
come on
thanks for keeping it warm guys okay you
see with this this is great
can I sit down yeah okay yes thank you
okay
already
need to know where I can find the fire
when I ask questions I need answers to
hurt you I just want to know very simply
where can I find
it's a bad time
I hate asking multiple times so one last
time where will I find Felix's file
director takes his office that's all I
needed to know
please done I know now you're very tired
I'm going to be just a ginchy what that
was dr. Schwartz we need to go to dr.
Yates office and get your teammates or
works
oh great thank you
I'll go to the office okay
great
what the is this attentional
medical staff dr. Yates will be in the
testing lab for the next few hours if
you need dr. Yates for any reason please
stop by the testing lab again proceed to
find them in the cabinets
crank them okay Frank
okay I got this
not a problem easy there we go files
thousand four days protein shakes my
favorite oh it's a code I'm gonna put
Sean it must be
I can't get it open I'm an idiot
yes I am my name okay all right
I this is where I start we can do with
this now okay what okay what is this
okay
yes does this patient have new
psychiatric condition what in the
history of mental illness Felix
Kjellberg yes attentional medical staff
if a patient wants to fill out their
full release paperwork they must get a
signature from the practicing physician
you'll find dr. gates in the lab no
don't do that
has the patient be medically cleared in
the emergency department what the
is this I don't want to seem too sure
this okay here we go again just
great
fantastic
where is it
okay great okay did it
hello excuse me are you okay okay I just
doing hair I said answer me I came for
signature release paperwork for patient
Felix Kjellberg is this your release
paper look this way to dr. gates
oh
okay Jesus Christ
okay
I got you you're safe you're safe
go back go back what's going on behind I
never ran so much in my life
what's your opinion of American
hospitals you know I can tell you don't
have health insurance and stuff going on
yeah it's a little bit more sketchy here
hello okay hey are you doing good good
good hey this guy yeah I brought the
paperwork out for you to sign so we can
get started on your restraining order
with Nikki okay
have you had any other incidents since
we last spoke so I'd like to be I mean
Thomas treat each other here so you want
me to talk to you and you talk to him I
think that's fine but I normally need to
talk to him because he's the person
who's gonna sign his name on the dotted
line
yeah well I don't want to be
disrespectful but officer and security
are two different things
okay packages where you understand
packages well it's from fans yeah he did
receive packages but from not from Nikki
yeah well okay this is for us to get the
temporary restraining order going and
then I'm gonna need you your signature
right down here at the box so you can
check off packages you tell me okay so I
just need you to sign right here and
then I'll fill this information in if
you want right here yeah right there on
the X that's it we're we're good
appreciate that thank you so much keep
an eye out okay I talked to Rachel is
Justin
Jeff this is Felix Felix is Jeff I
generally do overnight things donut
shops or late nights right in it's a
one-way street guys it's a one-way
street
could you guys people think security
guards are not compared
is a weapon I've got a gun okay good
just wrapped up another day
crazy as always but I did it and I'll
see you in the next one
brothers you don't trust me and I know
you don't trust sting you probably have
been getting a lot of sleep so we got
you a pillow
okay my favorite pillow yes